حالات وفاه سجلتها غينيا الاستوائيه
الايام الماضيه دعت منظمه الصحه العالميه
لاطلاق تحذيرات صحيه ولجمع خبراء من حول
العالم للاجتماع والبحث عن حل في مقاطعه
لا يزال 16 شخصا يعانون من اعراض ارتفاع
شديد في درجه الحراره والاعياء والقيء
والاسهال والسبب فيروس
الاستجابه الاولى للصحه العالميه كانت
باجراء تحقيق موسع عبر نشر فرق طبيه في
المناطق التي سجلت بها الاصابات لتتبع
المخالطين والعزل
قبل 56 عاما تعرف العلماء لاول مره على
الفيروس عندما انتشر بين عمال المختبرات
في ماربورج وفرانكفورت بالمانيا اثناء
اجراء البحوثات على نسانيسا ستوردت من
اوغندا ويعد ماربورج من الفيروسات الخيطيه
ومن اكثر انواع الحمى النسبيه فتكا
وعلى غرار ايبولا لديه قدره على التسبب في
معدلات وفيات عاليه بين المصابين تصل الى
88%
تبدا اعراض الاصابه بمارب بصداع حاد ووعكه
شديده والام عضليه ثم وهنا تدريجيا واعراض
نسبيه شديده وخلل في الجهاز العصبي
وفي اليوم الثامن او التاسع غالبا ما
تتعطل وظائف الجسم كافه وتحصل الوفاه حتى
الان لم يعتمد اي لقاح او دواء لعلاج
الفيروس لكن خبراء يصون باستخدام الادويه
المستخدمه لعلاج الاصابه بالايبولا
الخطوره ان الفيروس ينتشر بسرعه من خلال
الاتصال المباشر والاخطر ان الجثث
المصابين تبقى معديه حتى بعد دفنها مكرم
حناوي العربيه